les cendres de jean moulin repose
désormais au panthéon
après avoir reçu l'hommage de la nation
au cours d'une grandiose cérémonie
présidée par le général de gaulle
malgré le froid le vent qui balaie la
place et qui agite fortement les
drapeaux et les voiles tricolore du
cénotaphe une foule considérable au sein
de laquelle bien sûr de nombreux
résistants de l'intérieur et de la
france libre se sont mêlés donne un
émouvant éclat ou transfert des cendres
de celui qui fut l'unificateur de la
résistance française est tout
naturellement le premier président du
cnr le comité national de la résistance
d'un podium dressé dans le vent au pied
du cénotaphe andré malraux va prononcer
l'hommage de la nation à jean moulin
symbole de la lutte secrète contre
l'occupant
le président de la république voilà donc
plus de vingt ans que jean moulin partie
un temps de décence en doute semblable à
celui ci pourrait être parachuté sur la
terre de provence il devenir le chef
d'un peuple de la nuit sont cette
cérémonie
combien d'enfants de france aurait son
nom il le retrouve à lui-même que pour
être tués
et depuis son nez 16 millions d'enfants
puis c'est une commémoration des deux
guerres s'achever aujourd'hui par la
résurrection du peuple dont ce que cet
homme animal qu'il symbolise et qu'il
fait entrer ici comme une humble garde
solennelle autour de son corps de bord
après 20 ans la résistance est devenue
un monde de limbes où la légende se mêle
à l'organisation le sentiment profond
organique millénaire qui a pris depuis
son action légendaire voici comment j'ai
rencontré dans un village de corrèze les
allemands avec lui des combattants du
maquis et donné ordre au maire de
l'effet rangs serrés en secret à l'eau
il est d'usagé dans cette région que
chaque femme assiste aux obsèques tous
morts de son village en se tenant sur la
tombe de sa propre famille nul ne
connaissait ces morts qui étaient des
alsaciens quand ils atteignirent le
cimetière portés par nos paysans sous la
garde menaçante des mitraillettes
l'allemande la nuit qu'ils se retiraient
comme la mère laisse apparaître
les femmes noires de corrèze immobile du
haut en bas de la montagne et attendant
en silence chacune sur la tombe des
siens l'ensevelissement des morts
français
ce sentiment qu'ils appellent la légende
sans lequel la résistance ni jamais
existé et qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
ce peut être simplement l'accent train
ainsi le la fraternité
comment organiser cette fraternité pour
en faire un contre on sait ce que jean
moulin pensait de la résistance au
moment où il parti pour londres
il serait fou et criminel de ne pas
utiliser dit il
en cas d'action alliés sur le continent
ces trous prête aux sacrifices les plus
grands et par et anarchique
aujourd'hui mais pouvant constituer
demain une arme et cohérente de
parachutistes déjà en place
connaissant les lieux ayant choisi leurs
adversaires et déterminer leur objectif
c'était bien l'opinion du général de
gaulle néanmoins lorsque le 1er janvier
42 jean moulin fut parachuté en france
la résistance n'était encore qu'un
désordre de courage une fresque en
destine une source d'information une
conspiration pour rassembler ses troupes
qui n'existait pas encore or ces
informations étaient destinés à tel ou
tel allié
ses troupes se lèverait lorsque les
alliés débarquerait certes les
résistants étaient les combattants
fidèles aux alliés mais il voulait
cesser d'être des français résistant et
devenir la résistance français c'est
pourquoi jean moulin est allé allons pas
seulement parce que s'ils trouvaient des
combattants français qui eussent pu
n'être qu'une légion
pas seulement parce qu'une partie de l'
empire avait rallié la france libre
s'il venait demander au général de
gaulle de l'argent et des armes
il venait aussi lui demander je cite une
approbation moral des liaisons fréquents
rapides et sûrs
avec lui le général assumait alors le
nom du premier jour le maintien du
combat quelque en sus le lieu quel qu'en
fût la forme
enfin le destin de la france
la force des appels de juin tenait moins
aux forces immenses qui n'avait pas
encore donné car il faut que la france
soit présente à la victoire
alors elle retrouvera sa liberté sa
grandeur
la france et non des légions de
combattants en fait c'était par la
france libre que les résistants de bir
hakeim se conjuguait formaient une
france combattante rester au combat
chaque groupe de résistants pouvait se
légitimer par l'allié qu'il armait et le
soutenaient voire par console courage le
général de gaulle seuls voudrais appeler
les mouvements de résistance à l'union
entre eux et avec tous les autres
combats car c'était à travers lui seul
que la france livré un seul combat c'est
pourquoi même lorsque le président
roseraie croire à assister à une
rivalité de généraux ou non partie
l'armée d'afrique depuis la provence
jusqu'aux vosges gros battra au nom du
gaullisme comme feront les troupes du
parti communiste c'est pourquoi jean
moulin avait emporté dans le double fond
d'une boîte d'allumettes la micro photo
du très simple ordre suivant monsieur
moulin a pour mission de réaliser dans
la zone ont directement occuper de la
métropole
l'unité d'action de tous les éléments
qui résiste à l'ennemi et à ses
collaborateurs inépuisablement il monte
au chef des groupements le danger
qu'entraînerait le déchirement de la
résistance entre des tuteurs différent
chaque événement capital
entrée en guerre de la russie puis des
états unis débarquement en afrique du
nord renforce sa position à partir du
débarquement il devient évident que la
france va redevenir un théâtre
d'opérations mais la presse clandestine
les renseignements mêmes enrichis par
l'action du noyautage des
administrations publiques sont à
l'échelle de l'occupation non de la
guerre si la résistance c
ne délivrera pas la france sans les
alliés elle n'ignore plus les militaires
que son unité pourrait leur apporter l à
peu un peu appris que s'il est
relativement facile de faire sauter un
ton il n'est pas moins facile de le
réparer alors que s'il est facile à la
résistance de faire sauter deux sens
pont il est difficile aux allemands de
les réparer à la fois en un mot c'est
une aide efficace aux armées de
débarquement est inséparable d'un plan
d'ensemble
il faut que sur toutes les routes sur
toutes les voies ferrés de france
les combattants clandestins des organise
méthodiquement la concentration des
divisions cuirassé allemand et un tel
plan d'ensemble ne peut être conçue et
exécutée que par l'unité de la
résistance
c'est à quoi jean moulin s'emploie à
jour après jour peine après peine un
mouvement de résistant après l'autre et
maintenant essayons de calmer les
colères dans sas
il ay ay ay n'évite ablement les
problèmes de personnes et bien davantage
la misère de la france combattante
l'exaspérant certitude pour chaque
maquis où chaque groupe frans d'être
spoliés au bénéfice d'un autre maquis ou
d'un autre groupe qu'indigne au même
moment les mêmes illusions qui donc
c'est encore ce qu'il fallut à charlot
pour parler le même langage à des
instituteurs radicaux ou réactionnaire
des officiers réactionnaire ou libéraux
des trois pistes ou communiste retour de
moscou tous premiers à la mène
délivrance ou à la même prison ce qu'il
fallut de rigueur un ami de la
république espagnole à ans l'ancien
préfet radical chassé par vichy pour
exiger d'accueillir dans le combat comme
intel rescapés de la cagoule jean-moulin
à nu
besoin d'une bouilloire usurpée ce n'est
pas lui qui a créé combat libération
francs tireurs c'est freinet d'astier de
jean pierre deyries ce n'est pas lui qui
a créé les nombreux mouvements de la
zone nord dont l'histoire recueillera
tous les noms ce n'est pas lui qui a
fait les régiments mais c'est lui qui a
fait l'armée il a été le quart no de la
résistance attribué peu d'importance aux
opinions dit politique lorsque la nation
est en péril demeure la nation non pas
un nationalisme alors écrasés sous les
charités rien mais la donne est
invincible et mystérieuse qui allait
remplir le siège penser qu elle
dominerait bien tous les doctrines
totalitaire dont retentissait l'europe
voire dans l'unité de la résistance le
moyen capitale du combat pour l'unité de
la nation
c'était peut-être affirmé ce qu'on a
depuis appelé le gaullisme c'était
certainement programmer la survie de la
france en février
ce laïc passionnés avaient rétabli sa
liaison par radio avec notre le grenier
d'un presbytère
en avril le service d'information et de
propagande puis le comité général
l'étude était formé en septembre le nap
enfin le général de gaulle des six est
la création d'un comité de coordination
que présiderait jean moulin assisté du
chef de l'armée secrète unifier la
préhistoire avaient pris fin
coordonnateur de la résistance en zone
sud jean moulin en devenait le chef en
janvier quarante-trois le comité
directeur des mouvements unis de la
résistance était créée sur sa présidence
en février
il repartait pour londres avec le
général de l'esstin chef de l'armée
secrète et jacques d'alsace
de ce séjour le témoignage le plus
émouvant a été donné par le colonel
passy je revois moulin blême saisie par
l'émotion qui nous étreignent et tous se
tenant à quelques pas devant général et
celui ci disant presque à voix basse
mettez-vous au garde à vous puis nous
vous reconnaissons comme notre compagnon
pour la libération de la france dans
l'honneur et par la victoire
et pendant que de gaulle lui donner
l'accolade une larme lourde de
reconnaissance de fierté de farouche
volonté ou les doucement le long de la
joue pas mal de notre camarade moulin
comme il avait la tête levée nous
pouvions voir encore au travers de sa
gorge les traces du coup de rasoir
s'était donnée gagnante pour éviter de
céder sous les tortures de l'ennemi les
tortures de lénine en mars chargé de
constituer et de présider le conseil
national de la résistance jean moulin
monde dans l'avion tira le parachuté au
nord de roanne ce conseil national qui
regroupe les mouvements les partis et
les syndicats de toute la france
c'est l'unité précairement conquise mais
aussi la certitude qu au jour du
débarquement l'armée raion de la
résistance attendra les divisions
blindées de la libération jean moulin
retrouve les membres
il rassemblera si difficilement il
retrouve aussi une résistance
tragiquement transformer celle là elle
avait combattu comme une armée en face
de la victoire de la mort ou de la
captivité elle commence à découvrir
l'univers consacre un concentrationnaire
la certitude de la torture désormais
elle va combattre en phase de l'enfer
ayant reçu un rapport sur les camps de
concentration il dit j'espère qu'ils
nous fusillerons avant ne devait pas
avoir besoin de le fusiller la
résistance grandit les réfractaires du
travail obligatoire vont bientôt remplir
les mac
la gestapo grand dit aussi la milice est
partout c'est le temps où dans la
campagne nous interrogeons les
aboiements des chiens aux fraudes la
nuit le temps où les parachutes
multicolores chargé d'armes et de
cigarettes tombe du ciel dans la leur
des fenêtres et rier où des côtes
c'est le temps des caves et de ses cris
désespérés que poussent les torturer
avec des rois d'enfants la grande lutte
des ténèbres a commencé le 27 mai a lieu
à paris rue du jour
la première réunion du cnr jean moulin
rappelle les bulles de la france libre
faire la guerre rendre la parole au
peuple français
rétablir les libertés républicaines y
travailler avec les alliés à
l'établissement d'une collaboration
internationale
puis il donne lecture d'un message du
général de gaulle qui fixe pour premier
but tout premier conseil de la
résistance le maintien de l'unité de
cette résistance qu'il représente aux
périls quotidien de la vie de chacun de
ses mots le 9 juin le général
delestraint chef de l'armée secrète
enfin unifié est pris à paris aucun
successeur ne s'impose ce qui est
fréquent dans la clandestinité
jean moulin radis man show avant
l'arrivée de ces rolls si j'étais pris
je n'aurais pas même le temps de mettre
la joie au courant il veut donc désigné
ce successeur avec l'accord des
mouvements notamment de ceux de la zone
sud
il rencontrera leurs délégués le 21 à
caluire il y attendent
en effet la gestapo aussi la trahison
joue son rôle et le destin qui veut ou
trois quarts d'heure de retard de jean
moulin
presque toujours ponctuel correspondent
à un long retard de la police allemand
assez vite celle ci apprend qu'elle
tient le chef de la résistance
en vain le jour où au fort montluc à
lyon après l'avoir fait torturer
l'agent de la gestapo lui tant de quoi
écrire puisqu'il ne peut plus parler
jean moulin dessine la caricature de son
bourreau pour la terrible suite
écoutons seulement les mots si simple de
sa soeur
son rôle est joué et son calvaire
comment bafouée sauvagement frappé la
tête en sang les organes d'éclater il
atteint les limites de la souffrance
humaine sans jamais trahir un seul
secret lui qui les avait tous
comprenons bien que pendant les quelques
jours où il pourrait être encore parler
ou écrire le destin de la résistance est
suspendu au courage de cet homme comme
le dit mademoiselle moulin il savait
tout georges bidault prendra sa
succession
mais voici la victoire de ce silence
atrocement payer le destin bascule chef
de la résistance martyrisée dans des
caves hideuse regarde de tes yeux
disparu toutes ces femmes noires qui
veillent nos compagnons elle porte le
deuil de la france et le tiens regarde
glisser sous les chênes
du quercy avec un drapeau fait de
mousseline nous et les maquis que la
gestapo ne trouvera jamais parce qu'elle
ne croit qu'aux grands arbres regarde le
prisonnier qui entre dans une villa
luxueuse et se demande pourquoi on lui
donne une salle de bain il n'a pas
encore entendu parler de la baignoire
comme bloquer rentra aux invalides avec
son cortège d'exaltation dans le soleil
d'afrique rentrer ici juin moulin avec
trop terrible cortège avec ceux qui sont
morts dans les cas sans avoir parlé
comme toi et même ce qui est peut-être
plus atroces en ayant parlé avec tous
les rayés et tous les tons du des camps
de concentration avec le dernier corps
trébuchon des affreuses fils de nuit et
brouillard
enfin tombé sous les cross avec les 8000
françaises qui ne sont pas revenus des
bagnes avec la dernière femme morte à
ravensbrück pour avoir donné asie à l'un
des nôtres on sera avec le peuple n'est
de l'ombre et disparus avec elle nous
ferait rire de rentrer de la grille
commémorant l'anniversaire de la
libération de paris
je disais écoute ce soir je vais ce de
mon pays n'est cloche d'anniversaire qui
sonneront comme celle d'il ya 14 ans
puisse tout cette fois les entendre
elles vont sonner pour toi l'hommage
d'aujourd'hui il appelle que le champ
qui va s'élever maintenant ce chant des
partisans que j'ai entendu murmurer
comme un chant de complicité puis ça le
mode y est dans le brouillard des eaux
gêné bois d'alsace mais les hauts cris
perdu des moutons des sabords sont les
bazookas scorer avant c'est à la
rencontre des chars de rundstedt lancer
de nouveau contre strasbourg
il coûte aujourd'hui jeunesse de france
ce qui fut pour nous le champ du malheur
c'est la marche funèbre descendre que
voici
à côté de celle de carnot avec les
soldats de l'an ii de celle de victor
hugo avec les misérables de celle de
jaurès payé par la justice
qu'elle repose avec leur lot cortège
dhombres défiguré aujourd'hui jeunesse
puisses-tu penser à cet homme comme tu
aurait approché des mains de sa pauvre
ça s'informent du dernier jour de ces
l'air qui n'avait pas parlé
ce jour là elle était le visage de la
france
porté par quatre soldats le cercueil est
placé maintenant dans le temple dédié
par la révolution au culte des grands
hommes
tête nue le général de gaulle s'ils
mobilisent pour un dernier adieu à celui
qui fut jusqu'à sa mort tragique
son délégué dans la france occupée
lui c'est en présence de la soeur de
jean moulin lors oullins et de ses
parents que se déroule la dernière phase
du transfert des cendres
désormais dans la reconnaissance de la
patrie jean moulin voisine avec ceux
dont la gloire composent l'histoire de
notre nation